Walmart is taking direct aim...
...at rival Amazon's Prime Fresh same-day grocery delivery service.
The world's largest retailer is testing out a program,...
...where it will partner with ride-hailing services Uber and Lyft...
...for same-day online grocery deliveries.
Walmart will start testing the deliveries within the next two weeks...
...in Denver and Phoenix.
The move comes on the heels of another pilot program...
...from its warehouse unit, Sam's Club,...
...with start-up Deliv in Miami that started in March.
Walmart will charge customers a delivery fee of seven to ten dollars.
The Walmart store staff will put the order together...
...and the ride-hailing services make the delivery.